in the next few minutes we'll teach you
all the important stuff you need to know
about ux UI design we've condensed hours
of training into this short but
impactful video by the end you'll have
practical skills you can use right away
let's dive in first things first what is
ux UI design user experience or ux
design is about the overall feel of the
experience and how a user interacts with
a product ux design is concerned with
the entire Journey a user takes this
includes understanding user needs
defining user flows and creating
wireframes among other steps the primary
objective of ux design is to create a
product that is intuitive efficient and
enjoyable to use user interface or UI
design focuses primarily on the visual
elements that users interact with on a
digital platform this includes
typography spacing colors icons and
other graphical elements the goal of UI
design is to create an intuitive and
Visually appealing interface that
provides a SE less experience for the
user in a nutshell ux makes an app
enjoyable while UI makes it beautiful
and trust me you need both to create
something people will love using now
let's get into tools figma is currently
the most popular tool among designers
it's web-based allows for realtime
collaboration and is easy to learn one
of the first things you'll want to do in
any project is set up a frame a frame is
basically your canvas it's where all
your Design Elements live with your
frame ready this is where you can start
building out your user interface you can
easily add text shapes and images
throughout this video I'll be designing
a Marketplace for digital products this
will give you a firsthand look at how to
navigate the entire design process from
start to finish design thinking is a
widely used user- centered process with
five key stages empathize Define id8
prototype and test the process isn't
linear you can go back to previous
stages as you gain more insights there
are also many more design processes and
Frameworks that you might come across
before we jump into the stages of design
thinking it's worth noting that while
we're covering all the essentials in
this video there's so much more to learn
to master uxui design for that we've
created a uxui design Mastery course
that covers everything you need to
become a professional we've condensed
the best of everything we've learned
into this powerful course drawing from
years of experience designing successful
products so you can shortcut that
process and save yourself years of
frustration our course goes beyond just
Theory we equip you with all the figma
skills you need to create stunning well
organized Pixel Perfect designs you can
find the link in the description below
the video now let's get into the first
stage of design thinking empathize
before you design anything you need to
know who you're designing for you might
start with user interviews where you ask
open-ended questions this allows you to
delve into user experiences and needs on
a more personal level the goal is to
really get into users heads and
understand their needs pain points and
what they value from the data gathered
you can create user personas user
Journey Maps Affinity diagrams and much
more the defined stage is where you
figure out the main problem you're going
to solve and for that you need a problem
statement a good problem statement must
be specific a bad example might be
people need a way to sell digital
products it's not specific enough to
guide your design process effectively a
better more targeted problem statement
could be independent creators need a way
to reach a wider a audience and handle
transactions securely when selling
digital products that's specific it
pinpoints a problem and identifies a
user group giving you a clear road map
for design so the question you and your
team should ask now is how might we
create a digital product Marketplace
that empowers online creators to reach a
wider audience while ensuring secure
transactions here we're entering the id8
stage the goal is simple come up with as
many ideas as you can use whiteboards
sticky notes or digital tool tools like
Meo to quickly write down all your ideas
some designers also start creating
wireframes during the ideation stage the
main purpose of wireframes is to define
the dimensions and placement of page
elements information architecture
intended behaviors and navigation you
can begin with either low Fidelity or
mid-fidelity wireframes low Fidelity
wireframes are quite basic focusing
primarily on layout and functionality
they serve as the skeleton of your
design and are perfect for rough drafts
and quick internal discussions mid
Fidelity wireframes are more advanced
including UI elements like buttons input
fields and placeholder text while still
avoiding
details as your ideas start taking shape
and you narrow down your choices you'll
want to transition to High Fidelity
wireframes that closely mirror what the
final design will look like making them
ideal for detailed user testing you can
kick off user testing during the
ideation or prototyping stage but it's
generally more valuable when you test
with high fidelity wireframes if the
feedback is positive in alignance with
your objectives you're ready to
transform these High Fidelity wireframes
into actual designs this is where things
get exciting the core difference between
a high fidelity wireframe and a
prototype is interactivity this includes
clickable buttons Transitions and even
complex animations Now's the Time to
finalize the user interface add the
colors fonts and other design elements
that will make your design visually
appealing after your prototype is ready
go for another round of user testing
often how a user interacts with a
complete prototype can reveal issues
that weren't apparent in the wireframe
stage usability testing is your goto
method for this during these tests you
can observe real users as they navigate
through your product the goal is to
identify any parts of your design that
could be confusing or hard to use once
you've conducted usability testing and
made any necessary adjustments to your
design the next step is the developer
handoff this is where you transition
your designs into something that can be
implemented Ed by your development team
to ensure a smooth handoff you'll need
to prepare user interface specifications
they should include detailed information
about the dimensions spacing
responsiveness and interactive elements
in your design essentially it's a
comprehensive guide that enables
developers to bring your vision to life
with code finally the designs are ready
for implementation developers will now
use the UI specs to start building the
actual product turning what was once a
series of wireframes and High Fidelity
designs into a fully functional digital
product and that's it for this video if
you found it helpful make sure to give
it a thumbs up and subscribe for more
insightful content on uxui design